in the last video on taxing hamburgers I
did a somewhat artificial thing where I
text hamburgers with an absolute dollar
amount typically consumption taxes are a
percentage of the of the actual price of
the good so for example sales taxes
might be 8% or 9% of whatever you are
buying so let's think about how the
supply curve is perceived by the
consumers would look if we had a
percentage tax so now our government
instead of chart it started taxing one
dollar per hamburger let's say that
their tax is and I'll make it big just
to make it clear so that we can so we
can see the result of it let's say their
tax is twenty percent of the price
twenty percent of the price of the
hamburger so let's think what's going to
happen just like we saw in the last
video in order for producers to even
think about producing that first
hamburger they need to get two dollars
per hamburger for it because that's
their opportunity cost using those same
inputs that same labor and resources
they could produce their other
opportunity would give them at least $2
so you have to give them at least two
dollars in order to focus on hamburgers
and every incremental hamburger after
that the opportunity cost goes more
because now they'll be using things that
are slightly less suited for making
hamburgers and maybe slightly more
suited for making other things now at
that very first hamburger you need to
get two dollars for it from the supplier
point of view but from the consumer
point of view they can't just pay two
dollars for it
they're gonna have to pay two dollars
plus twenty percent of the two dollars
so twenty percent of two dollars is
forty cents so from the consumers point
of view I'll do it in blue they're gonna
have to pay about two dollars and forty
cents and instead of and right over here
if you want to get the suppliers to
produce about two and a half million
hamburgers per day they're going to have
to get especially for those those that
those incremental hamburgers in order to
get these the you know the the two and a
half million hamburger produced you're
going to have to give three dollars per
hamburger for the supplier but the
consumer is not going to be able to pay
three dollars they're gonna have to pay
three dollars plus twenty percent so
that's three dollars and sixty cents so
that will put us right about right about
there
and if you go further instead of four
dollars so if you want the producers to
produce right around right around four
million hamburgers per day you'd have to
pay them four dollars but the consumers
would have to pay 20% more than that so
they're gonna have to pay for 80 and so
what you're going to see is from the
consumers point of view the demand the
supply curve I should say is going to
look something like this it's not going
to shift it's not going to shift a fixed
amount up it's going to fix it's going
to shift 20 percent up so let me do that
pleat let me so it's going to shift
something like that so for lower values
it's going to shift
a less absolute amount because 20
percent of $2 is less than 20 percent of
$3 which is less than 20 percent of $4
so as we have more quantity and more
price it'll shift up more and more
because 20 percent because 20 percent
will then become a larger absolute
amount so the shift would look something
like this but at any given point at any
given point that is 20 percent that is
20 percent 20 20 percent is 2 it's 20
percent higher then the price that the
suppliers then the producers would see
so it's going to be 20 percent higher
than say $6 zero so this is going to be
a dollar 20 higher but you have the same
exact phenomenon that we saw in the
previous video in the previous video
this entire area this entire area was
the surplus that both of the consumers
and the producers share now now the
equilibrium quantity is less now the
equilibrium quantity is less it's going
to move right over there because we have
this new curve so our new equilibrium
quantity is over here so neither the
consumers nor the government know there
nor the producers are going to be able
to take advantage of this of this
surplus which was there when you didn't
have the taxation so this is why
taxation is generally considered
inefficient and obviously you have to do
some of it but it's generally
inefficient it reduces some level of
economic activity at least if you make
us all the assumptions in this model and
you have this deadweight loss the
surplus that can't be that can't be had
by anyone so there you still have a you
still have a
wait deadweight loss and if you look at
the revenue that the government will now
have it will still be it'll still be
this quantity so it looks like our
equilibrium quantity is now three
million hamburgers per day which is
about what we got in the last one and
obviously I'm not doing this very
precisely and it's going to be 60 cents
so 20 percent times three dollars is 60
cents so the height is going to be 60
cents so this height right over here is
60 cents and the width right over here
is three million hamburgers so it's
going to be 60 cents per hamburger which
is 20 percent of its price per hamburger
per hamburger times times three million
hamburgers three million hamburgers
gives us gives us one point eight
million dollars million dollars per day
and just like the previous one now the
producers surplus has shrunken the
producers surplus is now just going to
be this area right over here the
producer surplus is just going to be
that area right over there and the
consumer surplus has also been shrunken
it's been bitten into by the tax revenue
so obvious revenue and the deadweight
loss takes from both the producer and
the consumer surplus